congresswoman Alexandria Kazuya Cortez
lending her voice as her so called squad
joins calls to cancel rent and mortgage
payments during the pandemic right now
in a time when so many people are
threatened whose lives are threatened by
a pandemic their lives shouldn't also be
threatened by the fear of eviction by
the fear of foreclosure or worse okay so
is this the answer is it's the right
response here to discuss Fox News
contributor and Democratic strategist
Richard Fowler and Republican strategist
Aaron Elmore Aaron we're seeing you for
a second time this morning welcome back
thank you good to see you both Richard
I'll start with you you know what do you
think about this because it's it's fair
to say that a lot of people can't you
know pay their rent or their mortgage
the first of the month right now a lot
of people do need help what do you think
is the answer well this will be the
second month that we've got right since
the coronavirus of folks that have had
to pay rent and I think this creates a
real problem for a lot of renters all
across the country but let me be very
clear this also creates a problem for
landlords across the country because
those renters are dealing with not being
able to pay rent landlords are being are
dealing with the reality of not being
able to make mortgages not to be able to
be able to make repairs which is why we
have to figure out some way to provide
some relief to the American people who
are worried who are anxious about
whether or not they're gonna be able to
pay Mays rent or June's rent and so
we've really got to figure out a way to
do this and do this the right way yeah I
mean I was thinking about this I was a
homeowner for the last 13 years up until
February of this year I just sold my
house and I had tenants in there for a
long time Aaron and I was sitting there
thinking you know if they came to me and
said I can't pay my rent this month
ultimately that falls back on me and
then I have to be the one to then deal
with you know trying to call my mortgage
company see if they can help me so so
the brunt of this is going somewhere it
is falling on someone's shoulders right
I don't think aoc realizes that we're
not dealing with big banks here we're
dealing with landlords and they need to
pay their bills and they need to feed
their families I couldn't agree with mr.
Fowler more which probably doesn't
happen that often although I like him
very much
AOC I although she's an environmentalist
I think she believes that money grows on
trees because everyone has obligations
right now look we have thirty point
three million
and out of work in the last six weeks
there is a tragedy going on here there
is a crisis in America and her ideas
don't seem to have any solutions and are
not grounded in reality in any way
whatsoever Richard we like you too you
have a you're not better just to make
that clear
you cannot bet on foxnews.com right now
and it says that the coronavirus
stimulus this will help millennials the
most why do you think that right so what
I am what that op-ed talks about is why
we as a country consider the ideal of
forgiving student loan debt up to a
certain amount here's what we know we
know that for the average student loan
borrower makes about $48,000 a year and
we also know that they spend about ten
percent of their monthly income dealing
with student loan payments to the United
States federal government and a
federally supplied federally backed loan
we are really thinking about prime
plumbing of this economy the trick that
we've seen from the Great Depression to
the Great Recession is you've got to
make the middle and the lower parts of
the economy work and they've got a roar
and those books have to have liquidity
and by forgiving $10,000 of student loan
debt or less with these students you
will offer these folks who are now
adults right who are part of our society
who work in our restaurants who work at
our local bars who work at our local
retailers they need some relief and
giving them this ten percent back of
their wages will create automatic
liquidity into the economy and allow
them to go out and make purchases take
care of their family and possibly pay
their rent mmm interesting Aaron your
final word to you I think we do a
deferral we can't cancel because where
is that money gonna come from if you
made the obligation to pay something you
owe that money and that's just the
American Way defer it for six months I'm
totally okay with that it's unfair to
the people that already paid for their
college we when you spend money you
gotta pay it back so what we're seeing
is with the Paycheck protection loans
right if you are at the companies are
actually paying workers their loans are
forgiven by the federal government why
not extend that same benefit to the
American people and the millions of them
that have student loan debt this is
about pumping our economy and this is a
Democrat and a Republican problem it's
an American problem student the student
loan debt crisis is real and we can
solve it slowly by doing just this one
measure well I mean you know a lot of
things are real right now for a lot of
people we have so
millions of people out of jobs right now
and so we're all just trying to find the
answers at the same time Richard and
Aaron thank you so much for joining us
we appreciate it